no strings attached stars Ashton Kutcher
and Natalie Portman in hmm oh excuse me
apparently I saw friends-with-benefits
present benefits is a romantic comedy
about two people who decided to try to
keep their relationship strictly
physical while still remaining friends
and the complications that come from
that
the two people are Justin Timberlake and
Mila Kunis friends of benefits started
out kind of annoying it was like really
fast-paced like to the point of but you
couldn't really focus like on the story
it was just like things kept happening
and happening and happening and really
quick cutting of people talking to oh
yes mmm
whit whit whit II wittiness ha ha ha is
it really gonna be like this for the
rest of the movie where the characters
are so hilariously witty that there's
not even a pause for you to laugh but as
the movie progressed and as the
characters became more well realized and
hasn't got a little more deep into the
characterizations of the two leaves it
really started growing me and I had a
lot of fun with the movie eventually
everything like a movie speaks the truth
about these kind of relationships
because it's almost impossible to to do
something like that without there being
a lot of complications you can think
that but it's just it's more than likely
not gonna be pretty
in the end the best part of the movie by
far chemistry between Timberlake and
Curtis they worked magically to go I
mean they were just great completely
believe that they were friends
completely believe all the relationship
issues everything totally sold it both
of them were very good I like Timberlake
a lot in this movie this year that I
think the guys the future as an actor
and Mila Kunis is really good too she's
really beautiful and you know everyone's
never done
but now she did a good job in this movie
I liked her character too when I saw the
trailer I was like I must own this in
this movie oh my word
but she was only I'm like one scene the
movie is really more entertaining than
it is actually funny although there are
at least a few really funny moments
where I actually did laugh out loud
also Woody Harrelson plays a pretty good
supporting character that have kind of
interesting things to say that I won't
really get into it much almost spoil it
for you but he was pretty funny in this
movie I liked him a lot
really the flaws I had of the film is
it's really just it adds nothing fresh
or original to the romantic comedy genre
it follows that same pattern of all the
romantic comedies and you know I've
honestly just come to expect that now
because they really they're all like
that they're all like that I that every
single one they're all like they're all
like that though and so you pick and
shoot you when you when you can romantic
comedy like okay I know I'm gonna get a
few things but is this one a cut above
the rest is it better than the rest and
yes this one is better than the rest it
is a cut above the rest
I also like how the film self parodied
romantic comedies it talks about the
cliches and romantic comedies and makes
fun of them but the problem was that
later on the film it kind of did them
they have romantic comedy the most
important thing is to the leaves have
chemistry and they do also Richard
Jenkins gives a really good supporting
performance the movie has a good heart
to it too it's a silly fun time you know
it's entertaining it does have some
funny parts the stars have excellent
chemistry so I'm going to get
friends-with-benefits three out of four
stars it's definitely a great date movie
excellent chemistry characters that are
enjoyable and well realized take your
girl take your guy who ever take your
monkey that made no sense so if you
liked this review subscribe to my
channel and get stuck mine eyes